Oh people for fun and I need my insanity
to weigh on this pile of bodies I hear
you in corner me in the dark alley and
then me with my boo I was trying to as
fast as I could
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the burglars now you guys
mentioned when I play the boss superhero
edition there's a lot of other games
that are like this alayka the hedgehog
it's market buyers amazing please the
mark emu yeah the thing about the
zombies is that they're not exactly the
easiest thing that kind of and huge
numbers in the more they the bigger
their horde becomes it takes forever and
you guys don't understand because of the
scale at which I think I grabbed her by
the I mean I'm gonna eventually even be
all in the back but that's besides the
point don't worry about it what better
way to celebrate than seeing all the
blood out of poor unsuspecting burglars
this time we're not gonna suck like
there's been a lot of different theories
as to why Princess Peach continually
gets to the most remarkable one being in
1987 when a pair of twins went missing
and were later discovered to have been
in one of the assembly machines in the
factory
[Music]
ghost cheeks are where you sit on a
toilet seat and still feel the lying
around yeah you oh sorry
do you like my long and strong jawline I
don't have anything with which to mop
off my